the most famous police sign anywhere in
the world uncomfortably close to those
at the heart of power
one now investigating the other a
scotland yard probe into what took place
in the buildings around here at the
height of the pandemic
parties in the number 10 garden
invitations to bring your own booze
suitcases of wine from the local shop
and secret footage of aids joking about
breaking the rules
this fictional party was a business
meeting
all the time the met stood by leaving it
to a senior official sue grey to
investigate instead
on tuesday scotland yard relented and
opened the case today they instructed
sue gray not to release her full report
fearing it would prejudice their
inquiries what i would say to
sue grey is let's have that report in
full just as quickly as possible no
redactions no idiots no bits left out
and say to the metropolitan police let's
get on with that investigation all this
delay is frustrating mps it's in the
interest of the nation that we publish
it certainly in the interest of boris
johnson that we get this out and it
needs to be dealt with because it's
wasting too much of everyone's time my
constituents have gone past this they've
moved on from party gates and things
like that but here in westminster that's
all we're talking about the police
investigation could end with fines would
that mean the sack for those found
guilty there are people up and down the
land who receive fixed penalties for a
variety of issues that do not
necessarily
cause them to
feel obliged or necessitate resigning
their jobs in the next few hours or days
boris johnson will receive a version of
the sugree report but at the police's
request it will be heavily redacted
there'll be nothing about the details of
the more serious allegations about
parties that potentially involved
criminality
but once the police have done their job
possibly issued fines will we ever find
out the full truth
well i'm told tonight that there are no
plans for sue gray to issue a second
document
revealing what really went on here at
the height of the pandemic
one legal expert said the mess was the
met's own making the police could have
saved all of this confusion and
conspiracy
mongering if they had done the right
thing and investigated these allegations
when they first surfaced last year
a police probe consumes bandwidth
will the pm still announce plans to
level up the country next week is he
strong enough to resist pressure to drop
planned tax rises so much uncertainty
and clarity could be weeks away samcote
sky news westminster